so elon musk tries to buy twitter right
and he offers up this legitimate offer
54.20 per share to buy everybody out
instead of going to the shareholders the
board announces what's called a poison
pill
which basically bars elon musk from
buying up the company through public
means they may still entertain his offer
but doesn't look like it's going to
happen and it looks like we are about to
see one of the biggest
culture war battles the most significant
we've ever seen
i think elon musk has exposed so much
dirty dealing and it says a lot about
how wealthy billionaires corporate
interests are manipulating the public
and don't care about money because
they're getting money from the fed they
don't care about the cost they want the
power and the influence even recode a
vox.com blog says exactly this that
twitter is where journalists and
politicians get out their message well
surprise surprise guess who is getting
banned yeah it's mostly the right it's
mostly libertarians sometimes there are
anti-war leftists and some left-wingers
who will get banned but typically not
that's the power and they know it
we got a couple other stories you know
it's funny we're talking about elon musk
because world war iii apparently started
russian state tv said the sinking of the
russian flagship the moskva moskva
i'm sorry not specifically but after
this they said the weapons we are up
against
are from nato they they're trying to
maintain that the ship sank due to a
fire
but you you ukrainians are saying we
basically hit it with a neptune missile
so we'll talk about that oh we
definitely got to talk about the secrets
of dumbledore it's friday we're gonna
get into it i haven't seen it but
joining us to explain what's wrong with
the plot is brett cooper
hey guys how are you
i mean okay so
well you know we don't need to get it we
need to do right now
it's interesting it's a mediocre film
the real story on our end is that they
gutted the plot
for the chinese version
because dumbledore
prefers the company of men and in china
they're like no no we can't you know
it's a real secret yeah yeah right
america that's just for america so yeah
brad you want to introduce yourself yeah
i am brett cooper i am the newest host
at daily wire i host the comment section
with brett cooper it's a daily social
media cultural reaction show it's been
up and running for about a month now
it's super fun i come from a background
in
acting i was a professional actor for 10
years in los angeles went to ucla and
now i'm here in nashville doing politics
and culture it's fun cool thanks for
coming we also got ben stewart
i'm actually michaela peterson but yeah
none of you are biologists so it's okay
no ben josephstewart.com that's where
you can check out all my films all the
work that i do also ben stewart podcast
on youtube and uh happy to be back i
think it's my fourth time yeah man glad
to have you it's the fourth turning
that's right that's right yeah we'll
we'll get into that too maybe with the
world war three stuff for sure we got
ian hi everyone ian crossland you know
me and you love me what's up
and i'm also here in the corner pushing
buttons i'm excited to have brett i
always love having ladies on and
tonight's gonna be a super chilly
evening especially with ben it's gonna
be good all right before we get started
my friends you gotta head over to
timcast.com
become a member to help support the work
we do here these trips we do we came
down to the daily wire headquarters so
we could do fun stuff you guys if you
didn't see it we did this crossover
stream where i ran out of the trailer
and they're filming it with remote tech
all this is possible because you guys
are members
helping us grow the company hire more
people expand the business and uh we're
taking over the world figuratively with
your help we're going to challenge the
media and uh
you're going to get access to exclusive
members of i'm sorry exclusive episodes
of the tim castro podcast but what i
wanted to say is
i used to say
that if you guys like share subscribe
you share this video we could be bigger
than cnn that's right if every person
watching right now just shared the url
we could be bigger than cnn well ladies
and gentlemen
cnn plus has less daily active users
than we do so i guess you know we've
we've sort of met that milestone so
thank you we really appreciate it and
all of you who are members are part of
that movement where you can laugh
and say that you support real media and
cnn plus is failing i just want to say
one thing on that i see these
journalists constantly promoting cnn
plus who don't work there and i'm just
like it's sad at this point it's like i
know your friends have a company and
it's not working but stop trying to make
it happen it's like it's it's not going
to happen so uh yeah well let's let's
talk about the news again smash that
like button the first story we have here
from timecast.com twitter board utilizes
poison pill to stop elon musk from
buying the company the plan intends to
reduce the likelihood that any entity
person or group gains control of twitter
check this out do you guys know how this
works kind of so this is if elon musk
tries to buy up more than 15 percent of
the company they're going to offer
special stock to the other investors at
a discount rate so they can dilute the
equity power that elon would have
meaning no matter how much he buys the
other investors can buy up and take away
the power he's buying
they're they're effectively destroying
their own company to stop elon musk from
ending their censorship wow yeah that's
probably because the uh the saudi
arabian king is involved with prince
prince as well the saudi arabian state
as well so i imagine it's all good
elaborate i know there's a prince who
who invested the prince tweeted out and
it also said that the state itself he
said kingdom yeah the kingdom and but is
that just his company or well to be
honest to be fair i don't know i assume
that that was the kingdom itself yeah i
saw uh zero hedge tweeted that he
actually sold his shares i don't know if
that's true
the prince hold his shares i don't know
if that's true it's hard to know but i
think the uh the big play here is the
people who own twitter as we mentioned
the other day and and what we can get
into now
they want the power the political power
of twitter to control the conversation
saudi's aside i think it's vanguard
vanguard upped their stake to to say now
we own more than elon so there's some
very nefarious corporate interests that
want control of this mouthpiece that is
twitter
what do you guys think vanguard and uh
blackrock have a pretty substantial
disney steak as well mm-hmm yeah
interesting they also own green
which is weird yeah like they own two
percent of the others
it's important
yeah yeah definitely sorry i had to go
there that's true it's a little inbred
when it comes to the money so here's
here's the crazy thing right let me ask
you this question brett um do you use
twitter a lot yeah have you always used
twitter a lot no only this year see
because only this year's only for a few
months i know as of last so in the last
year it was like early 2021. and you are
20 years old
gen z
and you're only recently getting
involved in twitter yep twitter is it's
like the political space right like how
do your friends feel about it younger
people honestly it is not the most used
i think instagram and tick tock are just
what is most heavily dominated in
politics everybody is on twitter so my
friends that are in the political sphere
they are very active but outside of that
people have like a burner account
basically where they go to just look at
memes but they don't tweet anything
they're not involved it's kind of like
oh yeah i'll check twitter but it's a
very thing in normal circles that's kind
of outdated like oh yeah it's just
whatever and i never really had a a
reason or an interest in being on it
until i started i was writing for fee
and they were like you need to be on
there to you know promote your articles
and that kind of stuff
um but that's a that's not even true
yeah
so when i worked at fusion they were
they didn't have twitter uh i think it's
been a while but we had a conversation
about how
you know websites like to put the social
media links so you can tweet out the
story post post the stories and they
didn't care about twitter and ask them
why they said twitter doesn't drive
traffic
and so i was like okay for me i was like
twitter's really important but back in
the day when it was the free speech wing
of the free speech party it was really
important
now like i mentioned i'll post like a
picture of a hairless rabbit for no
reason and just just post nonsense
because the platform is garbage
twitter's kind of like the repository
social media network i i signed up in oa
didn't use it until night 2019 because i
thought it was crap but it's youtube is
where it's at the video makes you famous
and then they come and follow you on
twitter when they find out you have a
twitter account no one finds you on
twitter that's not how it works i mean
maybe not no one but it's not well
people found me on twitter when they
realized that i looked like bench peers
that's where i got the bulk of mine i
had like 400 followers and then jeremy
retweeted the side by side of me and ben
and it was like okay now you have
thousand and i was wow okay pinchwheat
on your account right now yeah you can
go check it out i'm bringing people
people were chatting female ben shapiro
but uh you're taller
i am yeah yeah ben's actually not that
short that's the funny thing yeah you
know we just hung out with him the other
day and i i'm like everybody says he's
short and then he walks up to me i'm
like oh he's actually a fairly average
like totally normal guy that's they just
they just like lying and making things
up because they want to hate on people
but anyway back to the reason i was
asking you these questions twitter's a
failing company
like yo we're i'm 36 ian's 75 yeah you
know
you look good though you look good yeah
no but like in all seriousness we're
we're an older demographic and you have
to get
young people involved in in your culture
if you want that culture to persist
twitter seems to be on a train track
that leads just flying off a cliff
they're not they're not convincing young
people to be involved in what twitter is
they have turned twitter into an
activist blog yo i called this
i said several years ago and they were
banning all the fun people the trolls
and the silliness and the memes i was
like dude it's going to turn into a
left-wing activist blog and it's going
to have 10 people and eventually one guy
and some people might visit it
but so why would a young person want to
go on a platform to be lectured by old
fogies complaining about policy yeah
yeah instagram and i think instagram and
tick tock you mentioned is it's pictures
and video i mean it's video for the most
part twitter's text it's a lot of text
you know you go there to read and
research essentially but not to have fun
i don't know is it fun for you i mean i
enjoy it because for my show
which is technically me diving into
comment sections and that kind of thing
i use it's my i know uh
i go into the trenches my friends um it
is it's the hub of my research basically
so i enjoy it because but most of the
stuff that i'm looking at is like you
know batshit crazy things and so i
personally enjoy it but i wouldn't go on
there if this wasn't like my work i
would probably choose tick tock i would
choose youtube yeah i would but it used
to be fun people would go on and they'd
post memes they'd share memes like crazy
and they would uh troll trolling was fun
and then we get this like the ceo now uh
parag agrawal he's like you know it's
not about free speech it's about this
the current state of things and having a
healthy conversation and it's like dude
if i wanted to go
to like a youth seminar where they
explained to me you know morals or
something sure i'd book it
if i want to go and just
post my thoughts and tell people like
here's a funny joke you can't do that on
twitter anymore so what do you do you
got to go somewhere else what about
reddit is reddit still i use reddit
sometimes but how are they with
censorship like oh it's the worst i was
going to say that's what i've heard i
know that yeah dude that used to be you
know what it is it's like it's like it
feels like
it like the school principle has taken
over the social media platforms yeah and
it's like we used to
you know throw bouncing balls down the
hall and then run after it now the
principal's in the hallway all day going
like hey you don't know that we're like
this is so lame let's go somewhere else
lauren southern tweeted out that it was
like only five years ago that if someone
got banned off of youtube or twitter it
was like global news and now jeez
you blink and then like a bunch of
accounts are gone i don't know who's the
most recent band does it even matter but
it's just it's disturbing how slippery
the slope can be remember remember how
fun alex jones was yes
so yeah was there a point where you ever
used twitter in any uh even a little bit
before never probably
and that's that's that's the thing i
think where you know i look at the elon
musk stuff and i'm just like dude
twitter is blowing itself up on purpose
yeah it has to be because that was
another thing that i felt with elon that
it's like
i love what he's doing the statement
that he's making but i also kind of had
the opinion like it already is like
you're saying a sinking ship there's so
much other crap that's going on in the
world there are so many communities that
need us that i mean you know everything
else and it's like this is great but
also no he's right elon musk is right
yeah he he he posted the top 10 twitter
accounts that some of them haven't even
posted this year like justin bieber or
whatever yeah because the platform is
dead yeah there's users on it they gain
a little bit of users dude
you know we were talking to jeremy about
this and he's like hey i said i don't
even take it seriously anymore i used to
post news stories now it's like i just
bro i post like chicken city is some
great accomplishment because i'm just
i'm like
it's a it's a garbage platform filled
with garbage people who
just want to just they rag on you they
lie about you they smear you there's no
good conversations there's no fun
there's no jokes you'll get banned for
saying learn to code i don't take it
seriously
and then you know he's like you have a
million followers though and i'm like i
don't i don't know why but i actually do
know why it's what you said youtube fame
well people will watch these shows and
then they'll follow on twitter because
they want to just like see their news
feed and see information but i can't
take a platform seriously if it's dying
and it is
i i can gain followers i'll put it this
way let's say there's 100 million people
that are using the site at any moment
sure i have a million followers so i can
lose a bunch and gain a bunch within
that sphere but it feels like the sphere
of actual
functioning
valuable users is just going down yeah
elon said it was like the town square
and that's why he wants to buy it to
free it i don't know if he's right about
that it doesn't i'm on it a little bit
but it's such a small kind of like the
bathroom stall wall it feels like yeah
more than the town i wonder if him just
saying okay forget it i'm not buying it
let it fail might be the right move then
try and waste energy and time pouring
all this money into some you know
relatively dying platform it's it'd be
cool if you could free the software code
but we really don't need it what would
be the town square though if it was not
yeah i guess i think so what do you
think it's not centralized there's
there's disparate communities the thing
about twitter is it's really easy to
overlap with different groups so you
know ben was mentioning that he trends
once every three weeks
and it's because one of his tweets will
merge into another community which will
then
go nuts about it youtube doesn't do that
youtube is much more uh rigid
you know like if you you don't get you
don't get shown like stuff you can't
it's outstanding siloed you can't retube
yeah
and so they used to have that your
channel page you could post stuff on
your channel page and all your followers
would see your channel posts that was
like in 2007
you i think you can still do that if you
like community yeah yeah you'll like
stuff and and but youtube can't capture
that so twitter became this rapid it it
became political because it's
what are you posting you're posting
ideas youtube you're posting videos
instagram you're posting photos so it
makes sense that the platform that
typically is about text idea concepts
information would become political news
some of the highest level stuff the
problem is twitter sought to
light itself on fire burn itself to the
ground and make it a trash platform that
nobody wants to use i thought it was a
doomed from the beginning i i 2008
there's videos of me in 2008 when all
the people like hey this new thing it's
twitter i'm like oh great another one we
just did facebook we already have
youtube what are you guys doing we just
have we have our
and they're like we're gonna tweet our
message our six word messages to each
other i'm like dude text is gonna warp
our minds don't fall into it i i agree
disagree especially with the text wiping
your mind but disagree on the prospects
of twitter when it when i started using
it i think i signed up in 2009 i was
like what's the big deal with this and
then within a little while i was like
whoa
now i get it yeah the rapid virality
like you you tweet something and if it's
good information if it's a funny joke it
ripples out way outward in a massive
wave that gets bigger that little pebble
you drop can become a tsunami remember
that woman who was on a plane and she
made that joke about aids oh my gosh and
then like her phone was off and then
when she landed they destroyed her life
she had like 200 followers do you ever
hear the story this lady had like 200
followers and then she made a joke about
how
white people tend not to get aids in
africa but it was actually a social
justice joke the point she was making
was that
the people who are mostly victimized by
this tend to be black
and she said it in a tongue-in-cheek way
this was like one of the first major
cancellations i think the tweet went
viral and she was just some like
random woman
and she lands and she like had a panic
attack everyone she was there were news
news stories written about her they were
going nuts
you know what ends up happening is
people like there's this viral threat
going around
explaining how elon musk will not be
able to save the platform because he
doesn't understand that web web 1.0 is
over the era of the wild west internet
is gone
and this guy explains that in the
beginning of the internet it was it was
the frontier it was a barren wastelands
yeah you can go out in the middle of a
barren wasteland and scream whatever
stupid ridiculous nonsense you want
because ain't nobody going to hear it
eventually some people show up and then
those who don't like hearing the crazy
guy in the desert screaming leave and
those who think it's funny stick around
and watch
but where we're at now with the internet
the foundations have been built it's not
just the frontier anymore it's it's it's
totally urbanized
the internet now is the world you can't
just go into the middle of the city and
start screaming insane things the cops
will come and tell you to keep it down
they'll say you have your free speech
you can't scream people come and scream
back at you a fight might break out and
so what this guy is saying is because of
that
censorship emerges and he's like the
only thing the big tech platforms want
is for you to calm the f down be civil
and i'm reading this and i'm like dudes
write about the frontier thing
wrong about the censorship and what they
want they the the people at
twitter
are all biased not every single person i
mean like the higher ups they are they
think they're not they are it's baked
into their rules they will ban you for
calling someone dude like when they
suspended zooby and this makes it not
fun and if you're not having fun you're
doing it wrong i don't wan i here i'll
put it this way
how many of you
on your day off would decide to go
somewhere so that someone can scream in
your face about how ugly you are
you'd be like ah no i'll just go to the
movies instead right that's what twitter
has become by
eliminating the fun
and by
their their outright bias
i think what you said about the web one
concept is definitely true and you know
you see facebook changing the name to
meta
the metaverse according to bloomberg
standards should be like in
i think they said like an 800 billion
dollar industry by 2024 and i'm just
curious how twitter would be able to
kind of keep up in that kind of
direction i know that text will always
be relevant in that respect i just kind
of wonder it's it's less versatile i
wonder if it could start moving that
direction if elon buys it and links it
up with the neural net maybe yeah yeah i
was going to say when i asked about the
town square thing immediately the first
thing that came to my mind was well
maybe it will be the metaverse and
especially if it's you know web 2.0 or
whatever this is where you know we're
talking about like cops or
you know screaming at you that kind of
thing i'm imagining there was this well
i think it was wall street journal they
had one of their journalists go live in
the metaverse for 24 hours and she did a
youtube video about it she like they put
her in a hotel room and they gave her
food and she had to do like all of her
meetings she worked out she like went to
bars in it and she just lived in in it
and she had to deal with all of these
random people and was like oh my god
maybe that is the future of our social
media and so imagine what censorship
would be like in the metaverse
i was just going to say there's a it's
something that truth theory on instagram
posted that there's a guy who lived a
week in the metaverse
he only had the goggles on
and uh he like he would whatever like
eat everything and he said that there
were like amazing aspects to it because
he would go to like meditation class and
he was meditating for like an hour two
hours a day um but like there was parts
of it that were making him go insane in
his dream dreams were really messed up
because of it dude i had a dream three
nights ago where i was in a video game
but it was realistic it was like this
and in order to get through the part
that i was at i had to kill a dog in the
game you know like in warcraft world of
warcraft you have to fight dogs and
stuff and but it was real and it was a
little dog and they were like i was like
how do i do this they're like the most
humane way you know you gotta choke it
you gotta that's all i did in the dream
and it was so disturbing and now i'm
thinking about these people going into
the vr metaverse and they're gonna be
killing things like a video game but
it's gonna seem real what is that gonna
do to people talk about video games make
people violent yeah okay geez i mean i i
i sickeningly
i agree and disagree i i think there
there are going to be um
it's very different from playing a video
game with the controller while you're
watching a screen and you have some kind
of avatar or first person shooter you
know we've seen many studies the video
games don't cause violence they can
desensitize in other ways that can uh
make violence worse if you're prone to
it i think the real issue is that if if
if you're a regular person and you do
metaverse stuff
i don't think you're gonna go around
beating dogs but if you're prone to
these things then this could exacerbate
or at least desensitize you and make you
know the tendency to divide a lot of
video games maybe i don't know 90 80 of
them are fighting shooting punching
kicking
like if you get that and that's all of a
sudden all these people are jesus sorry
well i've i've done a deep dive there's
into the metaverse and welcome to the
metaverse these two podcasts i think
into the meta versus bloomberg specific
and like just going deep on like what is
this and a lot of people a lot of the
execs that they have they're like this
is
huge but it's not like crypto it's not
something you just dump money into you
need to understand what it's here to do
and like why there are countries like i
think it was sweden that bought like
sizable real estate there for their
embassy and stuff like that so like you
don't have to go you can go and
kind of be in person but they're like
what they're really saying is like it's
not like a video game think
video games having to bend to meet the
internet so it's spatial web you're
interacting with the internet it's not
exactly like a video game so you're
right there's a lot of violence and
stuff like that there but this is gaming
meeting virtual like internet stuff that
you would do to go and get paperwork
done and the one thing i was thinking
about when you were mentioning the dream
is the the technology that's coming out
potentially being able to give people
eyesight that is only virtual but seeing
something you know like hooking it in
and they're seeing what they're seeing
like through camera they wear these
glasses in the same way that the heads
up displays mojo vision all the that
kind of stuff works but they're actually
seeing it through their vision so
there's things like that that i got i
got something for you you got you got
time for a project do some crazy yes get
a vr headset
bluetooth link it to a 360 camera
wear a backpack and have a 360 camera on
a monopod going up over your head have
the 360 degree view on your vr visor
screen and learn how to see in 360.
crazy yeah we we planned a pr with that
project a while ago but we never
actually did it even though it's
extremely easy to do
but uh the idea is out there anybody who
wants to do it do it i've
i i have mixed emotions but i think i
would do it yeah have you ever like in
school they they would put these like
mirrored glasses on to where you see the
world upside down and you would just
like throw a ball back and forth but you
wouldn't see it going up like this you
would see it coming down and up and it
was super weird but once you got the
hang of it it took like 15 minutes and
eventually you got the hang of it then
you take the glasses off
and you have to adjust again it takes
another 15 minutes to adjust back to the
normal way let me let me ask you brett
would you get the neural link and plug
your brain into a computer i don't think
so now
why not
i don't trust it i don't know i'm just
very
wary about all of it so i
was even though i you know live on
social media now for work i
was raised without television i did not
barely watch any movies growing up was
not allowed to play video games i was
not allowed to have social media until i
was you know 16 or something like that
one of the reasons why i wasn't on
twitter um just read a ton i was a
classic homeschooled kid um but i
i just don't really trust
that and also with the wasted part of
neurolink where they want to be able to
like control dopamine levels and like
that kind of thing i know that's part of
it is that it part of it some of it is
and it's like that
that's scary and it's like that part of
it i think there's something that's
interesting i think the technology is
fascinating and it's like if you want to
try go ahead i'm just not going to
really be your guinea pig i think i
trust myself more than i trust
technology
so that's the key right there is like
technology is doing something that
it's not that we can't do these things
there are ways but a lot of the times
it's like what's the easiest way to do
it take take this pill and then forget
about it don't engage with your healing
you know well it reminds me of just
everything these days i feel like i look
at the world and it's like you can get
your groceries delivered to you every
you can have you can use an app and some
suddenly somebody's coming and like
hanging up something in your house like
everything is digitalized to the point
that it's like i could just stay never
leave my house and my life would
function on whether it would be like you
know wearing vr goggles being on zoom
like everything that feels very tactical
and real in the world
slowly being eroded in my eyes and then
add you know big pharma and we're just
medicating the crap out of my generation
there's i'm looking forward to the
psychedelic metaverse people are going
to be like heavily on psychedelics
they're making patches
they're making patches for just that so
patches think cocktails mdma ketamine
slight doses but you go in to have
whatever kind of experience you want to
have i think that's why psychedelics
have gone ipo like gangbusters lately
is
this idea of also where the metaverse is
going these fully immersive experiences
where you like 1984 you almost don't
revolt against it it's it's servitude in
a sense but you don't revolt against it
because you have everything at your
disposal why get off the couch i was
thinking a new career might be like a
nanny metaverse nannies they make sure
you're fed and that you're able to poop
and pee and take it away for you make
sure your body's clean but stay there
you can get robust this is so just the
distinction here is the current
metaverse is like you wear goggles
the future metaverse with neural link is
you lay down in some kind of sensory
deprivation chamber floating and you
plug in your brain and then all of a
sudden your brain experiences the
metaverse
sometimes
about that where you're like in this
warm gooey liquid and you're hooked up
in the back of your head and
experiencing but
you every day
you know you wake up you go oh man what
a day and you're and check this out
you're ripped
you're as fit as fit can be no no and
you don't work out because when you can
plug your brain in it just control
controls stimulation so while you're
sitting in the metaverse your body's you
know just twitching and being programmed
to build this perfect
lean body in every way you know
processing the right nutrients craving
the right things or they just plug in
the feeding tube and you you put it in
your throat
and then plug yourself in and
you don't people don't realize
i wonder what would what would the
purpose of life then be if we were just
[ __ ] up to fight dragons obviously
when you plug yourself in and you're yes
that's it what do you think is the
problem it stresses me out what do you
think is the purpose of life
productivity and work
always
more of an objectivist um would you say
about like literally
real quick just to what end to what end
like how far would i go no like like if
if the point of life is productivity and
productivity and work to what end is it
just indefinite work and creation or is
it is there something where you're going
uh to leave the world a better place
than i started it or to create something
tangible um can it always be better
like i think so within the realm of
physical creation shouldn't there be
some point where we're like it cannot
get any better than
this or something you know
maybe do you think that i don't know if
that's
possible because i feel like human
innovation is kind of difficult too i
suppose i suppose the thing is dude
if if we were to say like what's better
it would be people being well fed safe
good medical care and things like this
and better dwellings better living and
we've dramatically improved that thanks
to capitalism mind you and uh with the
metaverse one could argue that you'll
have everything you've ever wanted all
of those things but it's more like
heroin than it is actually making the
world a better place
you're starving you're you're frail and
shaking in the corner and you're like i
i i don't want to go work man you just
plug me in the metaverse and then you
walk over and you're shaking you're like
super pale and then you plug your brain
in and then you flashes and you're
standing there six foot six super ripped
nba star and you're like yeah and you're
dunking
and people won't want to walk away or
it's gonna haptic feedback is gonna make
your muscles strong you'll be able to
live like six days in the span of 20
minutes and you'll have all this
knowledge when you come out and you'll
be a superhuman
that's what if we're in that way
like there's so much nuance with this
because like that's that's a possibility
for sure but i think that like what
we're talking about here is like what's
you were saying to to what end and could
the value come from being hooked up to
the metaverse like imagine if
7.5 billion were hooked up to the
metaverse
perhaps the planet would do better
you know perhaps some species would
would or the rate of extinction would
slow down but i i also feel that like
humans when you had uh was it was it
michael knows
and jeremy uh no michael knows and
jeremy boring were on last night okay
i thought sheamus was on he was also on
last night yeah okay yeah so so that was
the one that i was listening to when you
guys were having the would it be better
to save the dog with the cure for cancer
you know i was thinking about all that
and the way that they were putting it is
like we
i feel like we are here to engage with
what's already here and like to improve
upon it is debatable it's definitely
debatable but i definitely think that
like with
much of technology it's not that we've
been ripped from being able to to
acknowledge that
we have what we need here and a lot of
it is like if we were hooked up to the
metaverse would the planet actually be
doing better or would we be missing the
point well you know not every person on
the planet is destroying it so maybe
what we would need is some powerful
individual to create a system where we
can round up all of those that we deem
unfit and force them into the metaverse
i like this idea yeah you know and then
the world will be a better place once
those people are no longer allowed to uh
engage with it i think china would have
the stomach to do that right oh yeah and
then you know what we could do like if
there's a pandemic we could weld
people's doors shut and seal them inside
until they starve to death yeah
something about this will be fine yeah
cause okay that's a good point no one's
gonna wanna be stuck and imprisoned in
the metaverse people like any good slave
they're gonna want you to want to be in
it that's right brave new world not
1984. it's like the world economic forum
thing where they're like in 2030 you
will own nothing you will well what is
that what are they going to be trying to
be happy yeah that kind of thing that
makes me think of the metaverse but
that may be true
they say you will own nothing i think we
should correct that statement from the
world economic forum what they should
say is
you will own
the
dragon's bracers of ultimate power and
the sword the level 99 sword of
volcipheron nft and you'll be so stoked
this is the promise you only own a
license to the game that they give you
it in because if i get banned off steam
then i don't have access to any of those
games you'll own the nft you just won't
have a house clothes a car yeah you'll
have your pod though you'll have the
floating pot and the best part is
you don't have to eat the bugs no no
when you're in the metaverse the bugs
just flow through the feeding tube into
your gut and you've got to think twice
has anyone seen the the new blade runner
with ryan gosling no while ago it's it's
it's a glimpse jared leto's role in that
and what he's talking about how like you
know we lost our stomach for slavery so
now we started creating the slaves like
full grown adults and stuff like that
soundtrack is dope in that by the way
too but like very revealing the way they
look at like kind of the future of where
commerce is going and having like
virtual sex slaves and things along
those lines i think blade runner the one
with ryan gosling it's kind of an eye
opener people are going to go insane
from the metaverse because you take a
look at what's going on now with kids
and let's just try to be family friendly
adult content on the internet being so
just uh what's what's this pervasive
pervasive two-thirds of the internet the
the the eclectic nature of it meaning
like rule third was it rule 34 34 that
the one where it's like if there's if it
exists there's porn of it correct yeah
okay so the old rules the internet
imagine what happens when you're in the
metaverse and it's not just an image you
can look at but you can actually
experience and so the black mirror black
mirror did an episode about this where
the guy he goes into the video game
where he's a woman and he bangs a panda
people are gonna go crazy because
they're gonna get out and be like you
know i'd love to have a family with you
but i'm only attracted to clouds
it's like what what in the metaverse you
can go up to the cloud and talk to it
and do what you want to do you know what
i'm saying we're sort of at that point
with people in neo pronouns like i was
looking at a girl on tick tock recently
and she was like i identify as like
death death self and plant plant self i
mean there is like yeah plant self
and it's we're already did you see doll
self no
she like shaved her head and she's like
i am dull
horrifying one eye like goes you know
it's up there with the furries yeah it's
it's worse yeah i mean look look i'm
fairly libertarian if i don't care if
people want to you know
dress up how everyone dress up or
metaverse what they want to do the point
is at a certain point people are going
to
they're going to segment away from
there's not going to be a cohesive
society yeah
that's my point
a problem is that kids are going to go
in and with haptic feedback full body
suits on so they can feel everything
they're experiencing and then someone
else is an old man is going to be in
there shaped as a cloud and he's going
to be like come here
and then the kid will go up and
basically have sex with this digital sex
with this other person and it's it's
gonna warp because yeah they'll be doing
it with ai and interacting but it won't
be the same as with another human on the
other hand bro there's gonna be a
predator in the game
and someone's gonna meet it's gonna it's
gonna be a catfish dude you're gonna be
a 30 year old straight guy in the
metaverse and you're gonna meet this you
know attractive young blonde woman and
you're gonna do the haptic feedback
stuff and it's gonna it's gonna turn out
to be like a 63 year old morbidly obese
man who's like yeah yeah that's right
young man i think this is where the the
identity fluidity is coming in i
definitely believe that it if not
intentional it's working towards the
what you can become in the metaverse in
the metaverse there's already been like
um i don't know if it was straight rape
because it didn't have the functionality
in the game to do it but harassment like
several guys coming up and cornering a
girl and just not letting her out that's
what's happening like you can block
someone in the metaverse
you should call it metaverse cops
hold on hold on i mean like you just you
know you go like this you go
i'm for those that are listening i'm
motioning my hands taking the goggles
off
and then you're like but i had to take
my goggles off and i didn't want to yeah
against my will or you just like you
just click the button that teleports you
to the other room
that that could be another one but like
a lot of what i think this is doing when
you were saying the haptic suits and as
i was saying with the patches that can
modulate hormones as well as terrell
mcsweeney i think she worked under
barack obama she's now talking about the
internet of bodies and how
they're like the it's how's it going to
get classified is it going to be
something where if you have a handicap
you can fix it by getting your eyesight
back or is it an upgrade and then once
it goes that far they've already talked
about if you're a sex offender and this
was i think in 2016 terrell mcsweeney
was or 2017 she was talking about this
you you can have one of these implants
that can lower your uh create more
inhibition against some of those drives
of sexual predators so then
then they had to start getting into well
are they allowed to have those drives
what about
prison
and what prison is let's imagine we get
to the point where neural link is a plug
in your brain right because elon musk's
already done done that with the pigs
where they put the electrodes let's say
we get to the point where you actually
have a port
and it's wireless you can wirelessly
connect to the metaverse let's say
you're a child predator you get
convicted and so they say we're
sentencing you to 15 years in the
metaverse
but
in the metaverse
it's a mundane existence where you can
never act upon any of these urges and
you're internal in your own basically
virtual prison
your body is being programmed to do
menial labor so the prison sentence is
your body is just what can i get for you
today we have a double cheeseburger on
the menu in your mind your conscious
self is trapped in this metaverse
reality which is a prison that's like
handmaid's tale oh yeah i'm also scared
that about time warping in the game so
or in the metaverse on a game uh that
where it will literally feel like 15
years of your life but it's only 20
minutes like inception and they and they
can just
snap you in and you're like or you could
even do it yourself you're like i want
to live a life and you do it and it's
like when you come back you barely even
remember your your friends when you come
back there's a there's a show about that
we mentioned it i can't remember if it
was a show or a movie where this guy
invents the like eye drops and that
connects they can make their nanobots
that can pro they're programmed to make
you experience a certain amount of time
so the original idea is like it's a you
drop it in your eye and then you're in a
scree you're on a ski trip and so it's
like in the blink of an eye you have a
weekend in you know aspen but then this
the guy's like i want to turn into a
prison and so he makes like a 50-year
sentence or whatever something like that
and then
you know this woman gets trapped in it
or something i don't know something like
that it's crazy i think you might be
referring to an episode of black mirror
was it like some guys who are up north
and one of these like um like an arctic
um
fort or something and they realized that
they were not actually in reality
because they couldn't go outside they
couldn't do anything they were like oh
my gosh no it's a different movie i'm
talking about and there was a lady who
got stuck in it she was like screaming
trying to get help and she it felt like
years and years had passed and it had
been like 10 minutes or something that
is one of the most horrifying things to
me the idea of being able to get people
to believe that it's been a really long
time kind of a rip van winkle effect
it's like insane like i really don't
like the direction this could go like
who knows how we could psychologically
torture people i think it's called other
life
interesting
do you remember when i was talking about
the fourth turning the first time i came
on and it was like during a crisis
period the most advanced weapons of war
are used what you just explained lydia
seems it to me like you know torture on
the deepest psychological level then
getting back to the prison thing what's
interesting is is like you know prison
at least it has this you know um
attempt in the title of being a
rehabilitation facility
could something like that actually get
more targeted into rehabilitation
because i know that i think it was in
not nevada it might have been arizona
there was a prison where they just
decided to dress all the inmates in pink
paint all the walls pink and it lowered
crime incredibly yeah
and then there's there's this other one
in thailand when i was out there
training uh in muay thai
where you could actually fight your way
out and their world champion champion
fought his way out of prison you could
actually fight it out really like in
batman when they're like if you can
climb out you're free yeah yeah and this
guy did he became world champ and then
dave leduc a canadian came in and
whooped his ass and bearing bare knuckle
boxing wow but like i think there's more
we could do prison wise to not make it
the like what prison does to people i
think you could probably get more
intelligent with what you said using the
metaverse or whatever maybe plant
medicine something like that yeah you
just can't force people to do
plant medicine
at least morally you know administrate
psychedelics to prisoners you mean
ayahuasca you know how many people have
these life life-changing experiences
under right guidance under the wrong
guidance it could be the worst thing
what if we start programming prisoners
what if you know uh
we get to this point where
such bad things happen in our society
we just say you know what it is better
that we neurolink or you know program
the brain
instead of sending him to prison we like
you were mentioning with child predators
we wire their brain in a way so that
they cannot act on certain issues
impulses or whatever you know what i
mean like
turn off the aggression turn off
attraction because they haven't don't
they already chemically castrate some
people
do they do that i believe so yeah could
be wrong about that maybe i was a movie
not in every in every i i think i've
heard of that in countries i i know that
i heard that recently people in ukraine
saying like if we capture russians we're
going to castrate them but yeah that's
that's like a threat of like definition
that's in war as what i mean
do they do this because it's maybe just
some like fictional idea where
a a sex offender gets you know
pills so that they can't that is child
predators yeah is that i think so let me
look it up i feel like i saw but i think
that's interesting
because like think about like
a lot of people say well prison like
people don't commit some crime some
people don't commit crimes
for the threat of what might happen
so like imagine the threat of a neural
link in your brain where all those urges
go away and it's it's not up to you
anymore what if i mean man
neural link is some scary stuff man
because i don't think we even understand
how terrifying it can be it's not going
to be wired it's going to be wireless
why would they why would you need a
wired cable no it's going to wi-fi
connect to your brain and then someone's
going to hack your brain and make you
experience some crazy
stuff
and then what happens if someone hacks
your brain and then you're you're
feeling like you're being attacked by
ninjas and you're really just beating
the crap out of strangers
you know the lack of control is just
probably the most horrifying thing i
think social media is like the early
adoption of that the way people can be
twisted just by media well i was even
thinking with like metaverse stuff like
we've seen especially with gen z and you
know my generation that's grown up with
social media just like are all like our
slew of mental health issues and the way
that we are desensitized to basically
everything uh and the way that we
function
is so drastically different than other
generations i mean you look at um did a
business program at berkeley before i
graduated and we had this whole
class on like corporate psychology and
it was all of these hr departments at
huge orgs prepping for gen z because
they're like you're so sensitive you are
you know we have to basically rework our
entire structure to prep for this
generation that has been you know
royally screwed by social media so it's
like if that is just what has happened
with you know instagram twitter and tick
tock
like what the hell is going to happen
but the reason i asked you earlier how
you felt about it was because
i think what will end up happening
the metaverse will not be popular at
first
some people will get it for necessity
because it'll be easier to work when
you're using the metaverse and it'll
probably start with a headset eventually
they'll make some kind of simple eeg
interface eventually some people will
opt to get some kind of like wireless
implant
when the young people are entering the
workforce
it's going to be normal people are going
to do it
it's not going to be an issue of whether
you think it's weird or creepy it's
going to be like oh but you know
everyone does it well i wonder is how
much uh diet plays a role because you
were saying before the show that you're
keto or you've been keto for a while
a while and helped clean up the mine
yeah i found that cleansing the gut
biome and i wonder it's hard to
to measure like how much of it is these
micro plastics or you know estrogen in
the water or like have you studied this
stuff ben i know you look into this
stuff from time to time is it
quantifiable how much diet has
impacted the youth in addition to social
media because i for a long time just
thought it's got to be social media it
has to be and like i mean it's such a
nuanced question because look at our
topsoil and now look at our microbiomes
like the microbiome of the earth is
eroding there's like the amount of
supplementation you need to have the
microbiome naturally that our ancestors
had
is is going to cost you a lot of money
you you can't do it on low or minimum
wage so that's just the microbiome and
then you're adding on top of it the the
pcbs the micro plastics whatever else is
in there i'm hearing a lot about
graphene you know and stuff like that
even in water supplies so there's things
that we can account for things that we
can account for and then there's
sedentary lifestyle which is huge so
like there was this guy steven jepsen 80
years old never leave the playground.com
and he was taking people over the age of
65
and um because past 65 if you break your
hip your mortality rate goes through the
roof he was just doing things like two
buckets in front of them
bare feet picking up objects like
marbles and tacks with your toes and
dropping it into the other bucket
that would like work on the talus and up
here and it would actually
they would notice that it was halting
neurodegenerative disorders like or
diseases like parkinson's alzheimer's
stuff like that and then like making it
trickier like you have to stand up and
do it stuff like that is important for
the brain it turns neurology back on it
promotes neurogenesis and
neuroplasticity and that's just what we
can quantify so like it's a whole new
playing field because the like
everything from the soil to the way we
sit all day long and as you were saying
like a very sedentary lifestyle and
we've gotten to the point where we don't
need to get up anymore and the metaverse
is going to exacerbate that so it's
really it's those who want to engage
with health and decide that i'm not
going to wait for somebody else to do it
for me i need to do it for myself and
that's huge especially with like the
pharmaceutical conversation where it's
like
i mean you can look at how many kids in
the last 20 25 years have suddenly been
diagnosed with add adhd or any other
mental health thing and so you just
throw any drug on top of them rather
than addressing what is your lifestyle
what are you eating are you even going
outside how much time are you spending
online it's like sure here take these
meds that kind of thing we're just
royally screwing up our bodies but
they're very natural and this isn't like
some hippie holistic whatever it's like
no we have
it's very new that we have just been you
know throwing these things on our brains
right it's it's new
literally
the technology the pills the chemicals
didn't exist depending on which medicine
10 20 30 40 50 years ago yeah hormones
were isolated i think what the beginning
of the 1900s and estrogen was in the 60s
high fructose corn syrup aspartame in
the early 80s like that stuff's
relatively superlose all this weird
stuff we're doing the fact that you have
to say this food is organic over here
like we're going to label it as organic
is strange because now look at the ratio
of organic to non-organic
in in
stores like the fact that you have to
label it like that means that everything
else is not and it probably has things
in that that will affect you
neurotransmitters all the way down to
the hormones so like it's it's a lot and
you were just talking about like well
you said adhd but like autism yeah we we
laugh at simple approaches to these
things and we applaud pharmaceutical
like um profit-based ones whereas if you
speak to somebody with autism in a
prosodic voice meaning kind of lilting
poetic up and down
it halts in its tracks the uh the
symptoms of autism
almost completely and this was steven
porge's polyvagal theory just the way
you speak to them is different they stop
staring at your mouth and they start
staring at your eyes symptoms go away
and that's that's just one of many
things
and and what do we we don't get into
that conversation because just let the
you know the pharmaceutical companies
take care of that that's the narrative
it's the same with schizophrenia and
that sort of thing we have a very good
family friend of ours who runs a
fantastic non-profit and he is a
schizophrenic but he has completely
controlled his voices i think he also
has ocd i'm pretty sure he's bipolar as
well multiple personality disorder that
kind of thing he had a whole slew of
trauma when he was younger
um was in jail many many many times
completely turned it around is now fully
in control of his voices runs two
businesses and his non-profit and is
totally like carnivore and is but it's
all based on lifestyle and he's totally
off meds and it is wild to see how those
very simple i mean you have to be very
you know
committed to those lifestyle choices but
the power that you have as an individual
to make those changes to not be you know
at the beck and call of a
you know that was a really intense
conversation you guys uh just about so
much let's tone it down a little bit and
talk about how the russian state tv has
said that ukraine invasion has already
escalated into world war iii viewers
were told to recognize that russia is
now fighting against nato infrastructure
if not nato itself okay i don't i'm i'm
honestly really tired about ukraine
world war iii blah blah blah i i was
working on my main segment for uh my tim
cass channel
and originally i was like i guess we'll
talk about this because you know the
west is supplying weapons to the
ukrainians they did sink the russian
flagship the moskva and now they're
saying it's world war iii because
western forces are basically supplying
ukrainians and then i was like i'll talk
about elon musk because
i'm just kind of sick of talking about
this
and the bigger issue here i don't think
is the is the day-to-day play-by-play of
the war
and the stupid points being made by
pundits but
the fourth turning
so i'm gonna i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna use
that to launch back to you know i think
maybe the first time we had you on ben
we were talking about the fourth turning
and how we didn't know what it was gonna
be maybe war with china and now it looks
like it's going to be war with russia
are brett are you familiar with what the
fourth turning is no not at all all
right do you want to give us the
elevator pitch ben i will and first i'd
like to say that you wanted to tone it
down into world war iii
i just wanted to make sure the audience
also understands that yeah um so neil
howe and william strauss wrote a book
back
published in 1997 i think they
researched it for 10 years
and it's called the fourth turning and
in 97 when this book came out it's
laying out like sometime around well
basically there are seasons and it takes
about 80 to 90 years so every 80 to 90
years there seems to be a crisis period
so you go back it was world war ii great
depression
back before that it was civil war back
before that revolutionary war you could
even trace it back before that in
england with the glorious revolution and
a little bit further back
but basically it's this idea that
there's a
after a crisis period there's a high
and there's then there's an awakening
which would be the 60s 70s that kind of
culture and then there's an unraveling
which is like i always get into the
music that that shows you what the
culture is like the nirvana sound garden
this like it's okay not to pretend like
everything's great girls girls girls no
we're gonna talk about like something is
coming apart so anyway they said by 2005
give or take three years there's going
to be an inciting incident and that
inciting incident will likely be
economic and it will
steamroll into many other things they
mentioned bill gates and vaccine agendas
in in one sentence they said the the
possibility for a um a pandemic
they said the possibility for rural
gangs and um
or urban gangs and rural militias you
know at each other's throats i think blm
and proud boys and that kind of stuff
all the way to
um weapons of mass destruction or the
the thought of weapons of mass
destruction a plane being hijacked by
terrorists and um and then it all come
potentially comes back on
the country itself as a false flag
attack and i'm just like in 97 like all
most of these things come so so the the
gist is aside from their you know the
predictions they put out which we're
seeing to a certain degree it's that the
fourth turning is this the fourth season
the 20 the fourth generation or 20-year
period
where some great catastrophe happens
and so we're we're supposed to be in
that right now and the culmination is
what it ends 2028 but it should be
culminating 2026 like the peak the
climax that the crescendo which is the
250-year uh birthday of the u.s
who is that person who said uh i forget
what his name is but he says empires
only last 250 years that's his life
expectancy and in every fourth turning
the most advanced weapons of war will be
used so the last one you see obviously
nagasaki hiroshima
this time around we were we were talking
last time like what do you think it
would be you think it would be bigger
bombs or more death and destruction and
you said something that i thought was
very on point which was like the mind
it's it's psychological warfare
and and what we're talking about now
and and then dovetailing into the
metaverse i think you know it's that and
also this technology that potentially
even frequency wise can modulate
hormones
i mean i
i think it's already being used
and i would say that there's a lot of
people who say that you know fourth
turning is only like 75 to 80 percent
correct and i'm like they wrote it in 97
if they were 50 correct that's
incredible right so so is it uh and hold
on uh
joe biden remember do you you did that
thing where he was talking about the new
world order yeah he says in that
every three to four generations there's
this big i forget the exact word
first he said something funny
i was in what do you say yes a high
security meeting military military guy
told me this and it's like joe please
don't leak stop
you know clearance information
but what he was saying was that a
high-ranking military officer told him
that effectively the strassow
generational theory was correct or at
least alluded to this idea
joe biden says 60 60 million people died
or whatever
and so he says there's gonna there
there's gonna be a new world order and
he's referring to the liberal liberal
world order and what they're saying is
it's changing now with this coming
conflict and there's to be a new one and
we have to lead it
so it sounds like even joe biden thinks
things are going to escalate but let me
revise my previous position
and entertain a possibility here
uh
in the fourth turning the most powerful
weapons are used and and we talked about
this maybe it's social media the
psychological manipulation and control
of the population if you can get a a
country to worship you without firing a
single bullet of course you would it's
cheaper it's faster it's easier it's
safer right
you uh it's more efficient you save
resources you don't take out power
plants you might need in the future
but now we're seeing in russia zalenski
just he keeps screaming bloody murder
he's he's warning now that russia will
use nuclear weapons i got to be honest
when he came out and was like oh no the
nuclear power plant and the
international nuclear committee whatever
this group was was like oh no
everything's fine they weren't going
after the reactors i'm like this guy i
get it he's desperate for help ukraine
is being beaten down russia's is firing
missiles all that stuff
but then when he comes out and says
they're going to use nukes i go oh
really and then i see on russian tv
they're like nato is supplying weapons
to ukrainians and they sank our flagship
if the russians believe the sinking of
their black sea flagship was nato and
not ukraine which they probably do
because let's be real ukraine is said to
be one of the only countries or the only
country to become poorer since the fall
of the soviet union they have the
capability to sink a russian flagship
russia denies it at first they claim
credit if russia really does believe
that nato is supplying forces
nato is attacking them why wouldn't
russia say
nukes
uh hitler that's why he declared war on
the united states because they were
running weapons to britain before the
when britain was at war with germany
before the united states germany ever
gone toward think about hitler was a
genocidal maniac putin doesn't seem like
it he just seems like he wants the
territory so i don't think he's gonna go
to world war i don't think he's gonna
declare war on nato but i mean if they
keep blowing up russian ships with nato
weapons
what choice does russia have at that
point i mean you could always surrender
they could always surrender
or call a white piece and just end it
what if putin was like
you know
i don't want the world to end
so i quit
and then like they just stopped it's
happened many times in the past
if you fight a war to a stalemate on
both sides of side it's called a white
piece you just it's it's over and
there's no no victory terms no one wins
no one loses you brought up hitler have
you heard of tim snyder
he writes about like ukraine and
hitler's eastern front more than
hitler's western front and he he's fully
convinced that and i think he's written
seven books on it that ukraine
was
hitler's eastern aim and maybe the whole
aim um he like the the whole
colonization that was happening at that
time they were a little behind
potentially world war one i'm not as
advanced as tim snyder was but he said
that his eyes were fixed on ukraine
and so like that's that's an interesting
tidbit of history there in ukraine and
also like i don't want to side rail it
but there's this is a book by yuri
shilov ancient history of arata ukraine
20 000 uh bc to 1000 ce so it goes
through a lot of history the ancient
history of ukraine is incredible and a
lot of the spots where there are these
burial mounds with like 63 caves
underneath and petroglyphs that seem to
be proto-sumerian
so prior to gobekli tepi the earliest
civilization where agriculture comes
from seems to be right in this area and
i mean there's there's something really
interesting about like the ancient
ancient history of ukraine that also
where the symbol of
the um the swastika and some even say
the um the yin yang symbol may have
originated there that the the russians
the belarusians the slavs the aryans
have an origin primarily in ukraine
so
some kind of sacred land that it's like
a land bridge that's for sure it's flat
and it connects asia and europe a lot of
their most sacred spots were all along
the um dinipro uh river and also there's
cortis island which is in the dinipro
and tibetan monks claim their origin to
be there in ukraine and supposedly even
have uh documentation to prove it on
this book but the thing is is yuri
shilov an anatolic efficient leading
archaeologists and sumerologists you
can't find anything in english except
this book
and i've i've tried to get in touch with
him i've tried to get in touch with um
tim and uh heather lee hooker that have
um translated some of the work nowhere
to be found yeah the black sea uh port
makes it such an amazing piece of land
to control strategically you can get
into basically the the oceans and you
can get all over the continent just a
quick thing on the black sea
as i was researching a lot of this i
find putin's face everywhere and all
these ancient sites he goes into this
submersible check out um putin in a
submersible in the black sea going down
to the bottom of the black sea to find
an ancient ship
interesting
and there's
you'll see some of the images where
oh yeah
this dude it's happening you know if you
want to swear
what if what if vladimir putin was
actually just like nick cage and
national treasure
and they're trying to frame him because
he's going to uncover the secrets of
europe i did not want this power i must
free them yeah
all the way out to the ural mountains
all these ancient sites that apparently
uh belong to the same
core civilization prior to the sumerians
putin was everywhere i found pictures
everywhere visiting these ancient sites
so i don't know what it means i'm just
throwing it out there because it's food
for thought
well i mean look hitler believed in a
lot of occult crazy stuff too
and putin could be motivated by
weird stuff
no idea yeah the uh israeli i mean
that's a holy land it's all about that
area and not maybe not all about it but
a big part of it is
they wanted to be in the area where
jesus was so a lot of times i mean it's
culturally there's an importance to
people about being in a specific area
well you know i i definitely think world
war three isn't an interesting topic but
it is friday so maybe we should actually
tone things down and talk about world
war 4
the next one no this one will be a bit
more chill and we'll uh we'll have a
good friday night fox news reports
warner brothers removes dialogue from
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore in china the move comes after
the studio received a request to remove
lines referencing dumbledore's gay
relationship my understanding is that
that's like the main plot of the movie
but brett you saw it so sad last night
yeah so spoiler alerts i guess
the secret is that dumbledore is gay
which really wasn't yeah
i know no wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm sorry i'm sorry the movie is called
the secrets of dumbledore and the secret
is that he's gay basically but that
secret was already spoiled years ago
because jk rowling was kind of when was
that maybe three years ago that she was
like oh yeah he's gay and a couple of
the other characters you know or
non-binary whatever
still everybody hates her regardless um
but yeah i think
here's the thing i love harry potter the
movie was
mediocre it was subpar and there were
like three kind of gay points throughout
it like it started off with some and
there were some like innuendos and like
the middle part and then at the end like
you see dumbledore and grindelwald kind
of like have their moment of like who
will i love now
no they're just like they're fighting
but because they are connected
because
i forget what happened in the first one
but they were like blood is connected
because they were lovers or something
like that they technically can't like
destroy each other but that's crazy
yeah because like in harry potter
there's like
how is it that no one who ever once
loved another person ever fought until
now yeah like you have to imagine
that would come up quite a bit
you know it's like that's my axe
i can't fight her because you know
it reminds me of the same thing when uh
like voldemort and harry are fighting in
the wands like
com like combustion yeah if you use that
kind of thing it was that sword it was a
similar vibe i don't know exactly what
lines they removed removed obviously
because i didn't watch the chinese
version
but uh doesn't that make like the movie
not work if they remove that from the
movie i feel like i don't know what the
other secret would be it was like the i
don't like what then what would the
whole plot be it was very it was just
kind of like taking down grindelwald but
there really was nothing going on they
add like one scene at the end where
after the movie ends they're like but
wait what was the secret dumbledore and
then he like pulls up his underwear it's
got roses he's like i'm wearing rose
underwear and they're like oh that's the
secret i love it
i guess the other there was another
because dumbledore's brother is in it so
there is another dumbledore and he kind
of has like a storyline where there is a
secret that's not gay so i technically
think if you remove that there is
another oh they meant dumbledore they
were referring to the non the non-main
character dumbledore yes the ancillary
character dumbledore and the title of
the film one of the things you mentioned
that really bugs me is you know i think
star wars did it they ripped off the
star wars episode four the first star
was ever made with the what was it
episode
seven seven eight nine it was seven i
think they just re really just redid the
story but like in a different form it
was it was a shot for shot remake
basically so the force awakens is like a
new hope
did it feel like they did that with with
harry potter was it different enough it
was it was different enough it was not
as good the magic was fantastic though i
mean it's interesting going back and
like watching the original movies and
it's like i remember growing up being
like oh this is so epic and it's like oh
that's kind of campy now
it'd be wondering like that did that
secret make it to like oh you kind of
broke the fourth wall this is about this
is too much about this world not not
enough about that world you could
definitely tell one thing that i learned
was that this i think was pretty sure
people can correct me if i'm wrong this
was the first harry potter film that was
produced by hollywood rather than
british really
and i don't know i mean you could tell
there was something about it that i was
just like it didn't feel
right it didn't feel like it really sat
in the universe maybe that was it but it
was kind of like the last
what if they just you know so jk
rowling's been doing these screenplays
and the books she wrote were fantastic i
love the harry potter series seems like
these screenplays are just the worst
trash i've ever seen in like terrible
movies is she writing the screenplays
i'm pretty sure she wrote the
screenplays it wouldn't be funny if they
just like they announced the new series
and it's effectively like star wars a
shot for shot remake of the sorcerer's
stone or whatever but at the end it's
like the secret isn't the sorcerer's
stone it's just like some woke trash
about the character was actually a white
supremacist
oh this did you see the new lord of the
rings movie on i think it's on amazon um
and that's a series right yeah the
series and i saw uh screenshots showed
like a hundred and seventy thousand down
votes and like ten thousand up votes or
something and that all these people
comment on it's the videos on youtube
and it's a quote from jrr tolkien that
says evil can never create anything new
it can only twist and destroy what's
already been created
the book the master switch goes into
what hollywood has been doing lately you
notice that almost everything's a remake
it's it's this algorithm that's saying
we we know how to predict how
continually making spider-man
continually making batman and wolverine
and all that stuff we know how to
predict that and i think that's also
going to dovetail into these like
did you guys see what was that ready
player one
okay well
there was that racing game where there's
godzilla and i think there's also king
kong they're going to immortalize these
like archetypal characters in these
games to live forever so they they
become like almost like these fictitious
gods and goddesses from the movies
and um i would just want to say one
thing like voldemort you mentioned
the the two other names that are um like
in russian similar to that is of
vladimir and uh like voldemort
and so like i keep hearing that relation
between vladimir and uh voldemort so
that was anti-russian propaganda i have
no idea jk rowling what did you do
the new the newspaper trending tomorrow
it's like the son of son of superman and
but he's like he's a bi i think they
were talking about doing that with james
bond i think they're gonna do a
non-binary the producer was like yeah
they were like oh we're not ruling out
that bond could be a
a non-binary legit would love to make
short films
that you know in no way disparage
anybody but just make the point where
it's like
we take james bond we do an action scene
and then in the end the bad guy goes
james
are you gay and he goes yes and that's
the end of it it's like
you know and i don't know i don't say
that to this is not a critique of the
lgbtq community it's a critique of
hollywood just like to predict how they
would play these movies out how they
would do character development instead
of being like here's what i like i like
it when there's character development
and uh uh
you you you understand the character or
you relate to a certain emotion what i
don't like is when they're just like
dumbledore's gay
it's like okay look you know if
dumbledore as part of the plot was in
love with a guy i'd be like oh okay like
show me the motivation help me
understand it if the secret of the movie
is literally that dumbledore likes men
and they've been hammering this point
i'm just like guys you didn't make a
movie you may just make a commercial
where it ends with dumbledore saying
he's gay a social a social point rather
than good writing i was going to say so
from the like the back side of it
because i was next for 10 years and then
while i was in college my whole plan had
been to like then go into production and
be a producer and that's what i wanted
to do so i was working at i was working
at an academy award-winning production
company it was an indie
company and what i loved about it was
that it was they only produced like
deeply like character-driven narratives
like brilliant stories and during
blm i was working with them around cobit
as well
everything swapped and instead of i was
on like the development team so my part
of my job was reading every single
script
submission that we would get and
breaking it down and it switched from
brett tell us about the character
motivations and what makes these
characters tick what do we learn from it
what is the audience grasping at the end
like the things that i think are
important too
do we have a native american story we
don't have this we i mean we scrapped
like 70 of the projects that we had
agreed to fund and do because they did
not tick off enough of the boxes did did
ownership change or was it was just like
we're not going to produce so it was
just like went back to the screenwriters
like we can't do it and then my job
became not let's like seek out these
fantastic new writers you know read
whatever comes in it was like you need
to actively go find things that we can
acquire that are like a trans you know
female native american story so that we
can be
the social justice whatever i mean it
truly got so separated
from what i think is the most beautiful
part of entertainment why i love
entertainment why i love you know movies
and storytelling it was truly just
you know let's check a political box was
it like the ownership of the when i
asked about the ownership of the company
that you worked at did they change oh no
different people they're just they just
started acting differently yeah
socially
well you know what i was thinking is is
it possible that you know maybe in the
past 10 or 15 years
uh a species of small slugs
descended on earth and crawled into
people's ears and started to attach
themselves and take over their their
their minds and bodies is is that one
way it may have happened yeah what are
the 20 what are
i think they're called years i i wonder
if rain slides take over this kind of
came up with ben shapiro he was on the
show a couple days ago we did an
afternoon show that's going to be on
timcast.com i think on sunday it's gonna
be on we'll put on youtube okay cool and
we were talking about just basically
facts and how can you convince succumb
sometimes you just can't convince people
of things and i think when someone's
really agitated like when someone's
really emotionally calm
facts speak volumes it's easy to pay
attention and change your mind and you
know change your thoughts when you're
agitated and crazy almost nothing can
make you stabilize like no matter what
comes up it doesn't matter because
you're freaking out and if like this
wi-fi is freaky if all this this this
energy that we're pouring through the
air is like causing people to go nuts
haywire i don't know the word
and so they're they're not able to stay
cool when things like you were saying
social engineering when things like blm
and it may even have contributed the
rise of these social movements but i
think that's more like a ccp long war
game but that it's just overly impacting
people
because of the environment that's why
it's when people say oh we just need to
like how do you convince people of you
know how do you red pill them whatever
it's like just speak the truth it's like
you can't just do that like we can you
know talk about facts all day long but
if you are not meeting people
on their own turf if you're not you know
doing what daily wire does and creating
culture what timcast does all of this um
if you are not you know communicating
with them in a way that is relatable and
tangible and engaging and you know is
taking into account emotions especially
with the younger generations where we
are
all hell is breaking loose at all time
like you you cannot just convince people
with facts alone it has to be
possible when you were growing up did it
feel like all hell was breaking loose
when you were younger too not at all but
i was in a very
i don't know not contained environment
but i just didn't i didn't go to public
school i was homeschooled for my entire
life yeah that's great um i went to i
went to public school for three years i
did kindergarten
first grade maybe second grade and then
i did my freshman year of high school
and i was like this place is awful and i
left so as a result i was not in the
midst of all of that
i saw it when i got to college and while
i was working in hollywood but i think i
was so you know focused on my own
internal whatever that it just didn't
even phase me
um
i wanted to go back to your point you
said about you know facts and convincing
people actually think that facts
typically play a small role that's
almost always emotion
so you want to make someone feel
something when i was doing when i worked
in fundraising for non-profits it's all
emotion if you go to someone you'd say
you know hi i'd like to give you some
facts about this catastrophe we're
facing did you know that every day we do
x y and z and this is where they're
gonna be like yeah okay thanks have a
nice day no you've gotta they say the
first thing is create a sense of urgency
ah that's right you have to convince
them something is imperiled now
you can't just tell them the truth you
have to create a create they would say
create a sense of urgency and you have
to make them personally invested in it
you have to make them there's several
ways you can do it there's things like
if we're going to talk about a faraway
land we have to make you to blame
because why would you care about a far
away land oh because it's your fault if
we're going to talk about an issue that
does affect you then you're the victim
here and you've got to help fight like
we got we got to hold these people
accountable there's always a way to
emotionally trigger someone
either through a demand for justice or
through guilt there's an emotion you're
trying to target to make them take a
certain action i hated that industry
it's what i was doing before this a
little this is what i was doing this
summer was doing like copywriting and
you know what is it called i for you i
worked for an organization and did it
but where you're writing you know
pages yep and fundraising letters and
all of that stuff like there is
basically a blueprint that you follow to
get boomers to donate money to you and
these blueprints are typically they're
formulaic they're typically trash but
the formula is right they just what they
do is they know the formula there's
actually a step-by-step process so these
companies will give you a sheet and
it'll it'll give you five boxes and
it'll explain which each box needs to do
and then you write in those boxes
you know how would you convey the idea
so it says like one introduction two
sense of urgency three problem four
solution five pitch
and then you're like you know they say
follow this formula write it out
a lot of companies will pre-write these
things hoping that if they hire 100
people give them the script 20 of them
make it the rest get fired a week later
and so you know i always thought those
were trash because people don't like you
you'll see them on the street like hi
how are you doing i'm so and so working
with such and such we have a huge
problem blah blah blah it's all boring
and formulaic if you know how to read
people
how they move how they act then this job
becomes insanely easy but it is almost
always an emotional argument you're
either trying to convince them that
you're cool and right and they should be
on your side trying to convince them
that they're they're they should be
guilty for being at fault for
contributing to this or that someone is
screwing them over you're never just
saying do you care about the environment
yes
what's the most concerning thing to you
one of the problems we're fighting is
deforestation are you concerned about
the removal of trees in large numbers
people will be like i'm sorry i don't
have time for this and they'll leave but
if you say something like
when you go and and you know do x y or z
you are destroying every step of the way
i know you don't mean to do it none of
us do
but don't you think that you should you
know help clean it up a little bit
of course you should i know you're a
good person
right you don't you're not the kind of
person who's going to make a mess at
someone's house and leave it there would
you of course not okay credit card
please
i wonder and i've been again i ask you
because you're one of my favorite people
on earth no uh you're very intelligent
just kidding
i don't play favorites i'm talking about
the past is there like some history
logical you know reason that we're so
tuned into emotion
well i don't think we're hardwired for
fact we're hardwired for story look at
what we've done since time immemorial
sat around told stories you could be
like i'm going to tell you the facts of
my day i hunted this thing and i hunted
that thing but it always ended with the
shaman or the chief or somebody
wrapping it into a mythological story
and there's a mythos that basically
captures every generation every
civilization there's some kind of
narrative
like an overarching narrative one big
one from the bible is that there will be
a savior and be on the lookout for that
savior and i think
that's we are hardwired for narrative
and the thing about what's happening in
the world today i'll just say this
you don't have to get people
uh like if if i wanted to engage your
like um emotions to get you to do
something in the world and then to do
that to large groups of people
destabilizing people's sense of
equilibrium first which is basic
training they did that with me
you get you get the people into a state
of stress it destabilizes their default
mode network it almost puts them into a
psychedelic suggestible like state and
then what seems to be the context things
that i'm not making you do but i'm kind
of filling in the blanks of what's
happening contextually will create a
world viewer like oh [ __ ] because of
everything you just said it i realized
what i have to do and that's
setting up the set and setting
destabilizing use and suggesting and
planting seeds not being overt and on
the nose let's let's let's just
going off what you said this is what i
thought of let me tell you about the
hunt i went on
uh so i went out into the woods i had uh
my rifle with me
there were there were some issues
we saw the uh the buck
i lined it up we got it it was great big
guy
let's try another version so there i was
i'm walking through this mud
i see the beast
massive dim the lights
i get my rifle ready i'm jammed it
notices me
i take the shot we got it
we go over there this thing was
magnificent beautiful the biggest you've
ever seen well which which which would
people prefer to hear all right the
second one yeah the second one
you're driving emotion you're trying to
create a sense of you know what's
happening so storytelling you know i i
think about these uh you know we play d
and d or magic the gathering or whatever
and you've got these games based on
goblins and i'm like you know why there
are stories about goblins
because some guy went to go sell beans
at the market and while he's walking
through the woods he comes across some
ugly dude who's yelling about something
or other and he's like everybody's
always coming here and messing things up
this is my road i've been working on
it's like get out of here dude he walks
away when he goes back home he doesn't
say some guy helped him he goes so i'm
walking through the woods and a vile
creature emerges with a crooked nose and
pointed ears and he snarls
and i'm like back beast and i draw my
blade and so people tell these stories
someone writes it down and draws
pictures and like wow and then we
imagine these these vicious monsters and
these giant you know there i was
fighting the dragon and it's like a
small lizard you know homo florences
that hominid i think those are might be
where goblin the the fantasy goblins
come from those little small humans and
they were i think um they historically
would eat human children like they would
they would steal that they found some
new ones a couple of years ago
the most recent ones they found well
yeah this is what i've heard there's
also spawn new yeah logical stories of
small people like the menehune in uh
hawaii that uh and also like many of the
islands that apparently built all the
structures before the regular stature
people would get there there's stories
of little people and giants
everywhere oh native americans
i think they're called the giants
right but like cannibalistic giants
native americans from pennsylvania all
the way down to tennessee actually say
that there's
ballistic giants giants yep like are
they are they weird large humans that
are kind of naked and can all be killed
by slicing the nape of their neck
no
one
do you know what i was referencing oh
it's attack on titan oh okay yeah but
you left that i was like are you are you
familiar all the guys in the chat are
gonna be like but i guess not so guys
calm down i also i also think you have a
good voice for story you should uh you
should do some voice over like that oh
yeah i'm talking audio i'm dr fauci and
uh freedom tunes i love it but now that
fauci is out of the news cycle i'm out
of work man
well i think this is a great opportunity
for you to start storytelling again well
i i i you know i asked sheamus if he
would let me uh voice nancy pelosi on
his show and i don't think he wants to
but she talks like this like her mouth
is falling from her face i think donald
trump
you know i i definitely go over the top
with it on purpose because
i don't like her okay so maybe we are
enter in the psychological order i think
it's a storytelling era where and you're
an actor i was an actor ben i mean
you're a performer i went through acting
classes mainly to learn how to write
yeah tim creator performer yeah but i
was just gonna say like i
growing up as an actor i would get a lot
of crap especially from like family
members who are like you're too smart to
be you know being in entertainment doing
whatever
uh
like well everything that we're saying
that we are you know that humanity is
inherently you know narrative based i
mean everything we learn from stories
that's why i mean we spend however many
hours of our week
you know consuming movies and television
shows everything that we learn is
subconsciously you know coming from the
stories that we are watching and it's so
important and so it always disappointed
me when people were going well why are
you doing that it's like well i feel
like i could be this is the most
important work that i could be doing if
i'm you know leveraging
my craft basically
in a way that is meaningful and that i
think is aligned with my values there's
nothing better because that's the way
that people learn that's the way that
you change minds that's why it's like i
don't not not want to give up on
hollywood but not want to give up on
entertainment and the power that it
holds
um
i think what ian was trying to say is
that
when i tell you this next story
instead of saying joe biden mocked for
shaking hands with thin air after speech
i should go so there he was
i didn't turn to his right
in his mind the hallucination
of a strong man reaching out to shake
his hand
by then reached
but there was nothing
but the best part of this the stars and
stripes is on top of all of that
happening
the band's playing it oh yeah yeah so so
joe biden claims that he puts the
smartest and the best in power i don't
understand this is this is just
arrangement well they hated donald trump
yeah and they were willing to take
the craziest
laziest out of his mindiest
so that's what we get i don't think joe
biden will be able to run in 2024
absolutely not i mean ben was saying
that they're going to strap him to a
gurney but i'm like come on
yeah i guess but even that's not going
to work maybe he'll run and then try and
make somebody else look good you know
what his slogan would be
tuning on a shovel to pressure
or next no resin yeah and um uh batacaf
here here's a new one remember when he
said the united states can be summed up
in one word and he said i'll serve her
for minimum yeah
or something like that i didn't i didn't
my favorite is just we're back
we're back we're back the only thing you
can actually say coherently is we're
back
oh he could say come on man that's it
yeah look at that it's going to get real
he's good at saying putin caused
inflation
or go get him that was the end of his uh
state of the union his catchphrase it's
not my fault it's putin's fault it's not
my fault everything yeah he like slips
on a banana peel oh putin
do what did you guys see that he got
shot on by a bird yes yeah and he
everybody was like always going to blame
well
made a video earlier i think analyzing
it what'd you come up with so snope says
he wasn't pooped on it was actually corn
or a corn i said it was a
corn by product
oh my gosh oh it was a literal corn pop
he was standing next to a big pile of
corn
at an ethanol plant where they take corn
and turn into ethanol and so they said
it clearly was corn and when they show
in slow motion you can see it hits him
and it does break apart like
bits and not goop
however here's the issue
the new york post said it was bird poop
snopes and many other outside it was
corn and i'm like no one actually knows
none of you can prove it the white house
claims it was corn you don't know that
so here's what i say
the splatter on his lapel
the corn retains it's it's it's it's it
looks like if it was corn and it might
be
it's in a viscous matter of some sort
because
if powdered corn ball hit you the whole
thing would break apart
if there was a wet ball with corn in it
it would hit you
and then corn bits would splatter down
but it would retain its splatter shape
because there's a viscous material
holding it together
i say it's possible that there was a
bird in there that ate a bunch of the
corn and then pooped it out on him and
it was in its poop or the simple answer
is why are fact checkers claiming they
know what it is when they don't
by all means say we don't know if it was
bird poop i'm fine with that something
fell on him sure but then they were like
fact check biden wasn't pooped on i'm
like you didn't fact-check that's your
opinion yeah because you could like zoom
in on the photo and it's like it doesn't
look like typical bird poop it's not
like white it has i mean it does now
that you said the point i hadn't seen
that it does kind of look more like that
i mean i got pooped on here the other
day but they they pulled it it does not
look like that they called it one of
them by product because they couldn't
even say it was corn a corn by-product
it was like partially digested corn i
imagine that birds can't digest it fully
or something or they ate too much like
that giant that giant mound a bird could
have just eaten until i got sick and
barfed on them from maybe yeah or or
maybe it was a mother bird carrying food
around to bring back to the babies in
the nest oh yeah
you know
i had a moment i was walking up to the
front door of the daily wire building
and as i'm walking i'm about five feet
from the wall in the door and i hear up
like a splatter and i look and i see a
little white splotch and i was like oh
that was close and i look up and there
was a little bird butt right over the
edge it was just it was it was just
really awesome i could see like there's
a little bird standing there and his
butt hanging over i'm like he just took
a dump what have you guys been crapped
on
i'll go first if you want well burn last
week well no it was like two weeks ago i
did a hit on ben's show and i was
walking back and it was right there and
i was like
yeah i took the bird
the snake the snake was interesting
because it was like this white stuff
just came out of the bottom of it on the
knee it's kind of neat oh uh human
babies oh yeah yeah yeah so i get pooped
on often and and rabbits
oh yeah which actually isn't i mean they
they're relentless [ __ ] but i mean
like it's it's just these little dry
little fertilizers but you know they
they also eat
their own poop yeah they do they don't
want to say their own babies they don't
really
they don't really eat their own poop
what they're eating is
when the rabbits eat plant matter it has
to go through their system more than
once so some sometimes poop comes out
and sometimes it looks like poop but
it's actually just partially digested
plant matter they turn around and eat it
again
yeah rabbits people got to understand
rabbits are not pets nope that's crazy
to me that people like well they freak
me out too yeah they're they're white
ones with the red eyes
albino are they considered
albino they're they're delicate they
have delicate uh um uh systems people
you can't really bathe them like they're
not great pets like people get them for
their kids chew everything but they're
they're
high maintenance get him a guinea pig
yeah well these rabbits attack our feet
they're not smart you know like i mean
they're they're fun actually but like
we'll like it'll be dark and i'm walking
through the house and they'll just run
straight from my feet not realizing like
i could crush you dude on accident what
do they think it is not that you know
but they're super playful like if if i
run away they'll run after me
you know and my kids love just running
across the house
do you get them fixed no we just have
two boys oh okay um but they still hump
each other like crazy really yeah we
funny to watch i had some rabbits and
you know we we understood
you know their warning they
good rabbit you know dealers or pet
shops will will explain to you like how
you take care of the rabbits so when i
was in miami we actually had a whole
room with just two rabbits in it it
wasn't that big of a room but it was
like it's a decently sized room we just
the rabbits had the room to themselves
they poop everywhere and we'd feed him
and then we clean and stuff but they
started getting into it because it was a
boy and a girl and so it didn't really
work out because you know rabbits are
and the girl when she didn't want it she
would jump like eight feet in the air
because we put up a big barrier so the
room was like a sun room it was like
it was a room but the door was just
always open so we put a big thing in
front of it and she would just
straight over it and one day i go in
there and she's gone we find her
upstairs hiding because the dude rabbit
was like you know
he was he was oppressing her wow
good nice way of saying it
what i like about it is like there's a
lot of fertilizer and i've gotten
seriously into the importance of topsoil
topsoil and just
the microbes in the soil and there's
like farmers around tennessee down in
summertown that are like within six
years gonna have like several feet of
topsoil on their farm like really doing
it incredibly so but they have like
guineas water buffalo different cows
like tons of different animals and
they're doing it right so that's why i
don't mind seeing the the bunny crap
everywhere i just go around up yeah you
know what this is the body pose biden
getting pooped on thing makes me think
of the bernie sanders when the bird
landed on his podium oh yeah that was
that it was like a magical moment people
yeah and then here's the other magical
moment yeah well so we we have uh uh you
guys probably know it chicken city oh
yeah and those things poop oh my gosh
everywhere
so what i love about them is that
they're smart enough not to drink
poop water but they're not smart enough
not to poop in their water so it's like
you hand them water they'll drink it
they'll turn around just take a dump
right in it and look at it and go like
i'm not drinking that it's like well you
did it dude but uh
when you go into the chicken coop i
always tell people because when people
come over they'll be like oh can i come
check them out i'll be yeah but your
feet are gonna be covered caked
in just chicken crap and they're like oh
you wash them off afterwards so you can
just not go in there and you know
chickens they poop is it safe enough to
put plastic bags on your feet i was just
thinking about these painters those
painter ones
yeah just go with it just be one with
that i i i when i go back around yeah
when i go home to my family's farm it's
like i know for a fact that it's like
i'm not coming out on skates it must be
good for your biome to be like was it
joey salatin i think is his name is it
uh joel salatin
is all about getting in there with the
pig feces and like it how it enhances
your biome and your immune system he'd
be i think i'm healthier because i was
you know playing in the dirt as well
yeah sure because i wasn't a purell kid
purell kid yeah that actually things are
scary help with allergies early exposure
helps with allergies it's you just got
to be careful with like the the parasite
cycles but actually having a diversity
of animals they'll eat each other's crap
and break the parasite cycles as well
if you have them roaming around the same
ground they'll break the parasite cycles
and also keeping quail
is really incredible because they don't
make a ton of noise their eggs are
really dense uh you know nutrient dense
and um yeah they don't make much noise
so you can be in kind of like an urban
environment and you won't have that
noise all the time i think i need some
quails yeah that sounds like chickens
are noisy yeah yeah man we got roberto
and then we got roberto
he had a kid and they just yell non-stop
the ladies are cool
no no no no no no i think the ladies are
actually worse really so yeah the
roosters are loud but the girls just
complain all day they're not really
complaining they complain to each other
they're actually really happy but they
go around and they go like brock
like i'll hear the cons so it's one
thing to hear a cock-a-doodle do once in
a while or the crowing it's another
thing when for like 30 minutes you're
hanging
out what is are they laying an egg when
they do that so typically it's probably
more than one chicken and they're doing
the egg song what is that they they they
lay an egg and then they sing oh wow
yeah you guys ever had pink cheeks no i
would love to have you well i will so my
my mother's birthday was in february and
her birthday present for me was a pet
pig
but it's out there but yeah i have pig
what teacup pig no she's no she's going
to be full size her name is nora but i
got her she was like two months old i
was here already i had her delivered to
my mom had it all set up and i don't
know how big she is now her name's nora
that animal
i mean so loud you if she does not want
to be touched she's super sweet and she
like comes when you call her she's like
a dog but if you touch her in a weird
way i mean it's like squishy all hell i
mean the loudest thing on the farm by
like a long shot and she has all those
birds and everything but truly
let's go to let's go to super chats if
you have not already super chat
and send us your questions also smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
want to help out that grassroots
marketing
we're already bigger than cnn plus so
all right mission accomplished i guess
but
share the show anyway
and become a member at timcast.com
we're already bigger than cnn plus but
you join anyway next will be bigger than
i don't know fox nation yeah fox nation
yeah we'll beat them all right all right
send us your super chats let's see what
you guys got
all right
do for you says currently driving up
from georgia to see you guys tomorrow
you're a hero to me tim i really
appreciate it i think the current plan
is that we're going to be at redneck
riviera downtown nashville from 1 30 to
2 30.
i think we'll all be there
yeah so i think i think a good hour is
enough to get a handful of songs in for
everybody i i might play two we'll see
what happens and then we gotta we got a
hard stop to get out of there by 2 30.
we got to be in the car and be on the
road because i got to make it back to
west virginia
to get back to work
all right colin your buddy says we're
writing stories for the chickens in
chicken city
roberto is the mayor of chicken city
after being a weathervane model and
having an affair with margaret hatcher
mayor roberto 2024 and roberto jr is his
illegitimate son who's come to usurp his
role scandal
not my father in in reality though you
know roberto jr is starting to
impose himself on roberto's ladies
and roberto's not having it the craziest
thing is that
you guys chickens do not have the same
genetics as us so they inbreed
they do it's called line breeding you're
not supposed to do it too much but it
happens
and they don't care they do not have
familial relationships so like roberto
sees his daughter and roberto junior
sees his mom and they just like don't
care they just that's that's that's how
it goes dinosaurs do that too i guess
then
yeah chickens or dinosaurs
i've always wondered how dinosaurs
actually do it there you go you look at
those huge tails
how did they mount one another
it's just a weird very aggressively yeah
i don't spend a lot of time trying to
figure that out
all right clef the misfit says hey tim
you said you're a twitter shareholder
too why don't you reach out to other
shareholders and launch a class-action
lawsuit since twitter violated their
fiduciary duty i have 22 shares and i
bought them after elon musk bought
because i was like
this is a good investment i mean elon
musk will be a great leader for the
company that's fantastic so after i
heard i was like i'll go on twitter and
see what's up and i bought some but um
i may have had one before and i think i
just bought them
now it's like if elon pulls out of
twitter because of this shady dealing
i'm gonna end up losing a bunch of money
i'll be kind of pissed but i'm not doing
this for any kind of lawsuit or anything
i i haven't i have a brokerage account
or whatever with like a thousand bucks
in it and i was like oh yeah twitter i
guess why not i wasn't really thinking i
don't want to be involved in any other
stuff if i was like a legitimate big
investor then definitely because i think
they're screwing over the shareholders
no doubt because they're does their nuts
maybe everybody should should should you
know buy in
all right daniel kay says your honest
coverage of florida has been much
appreciated tampa a democrat stronghold
in florida has a green beret running for
congress jay collins it's a long shot
flipping tampa red but i feel like
collins has a real chance at it it would
be great to see him on your show
we will take a look
all right let's grab some super chats as
the raced cars keep going
double a says femme shapiro doesn't look
the same without her leg up on the chair
sorry guys sorry
that's how i sit too comfortable yeah
it's the knee
oh wow what's this brad pitt's junk says
congrats to sticks on the birth of his
daughter earlier this week hope you guys
can have him on next time he's stateside
wow yes congratulations stix is
fantastic he's a good dude yeah
always been a big fan of six hex and
hammer
steven white says tim and crew the
trending movies on netflix are war
movies saving private ryan the imaginary
game it's almost like they're trying to
push world war three
what did i get recommended i you know i
i i've been watching dc's legends of
tomorrow and then season six i just
stopped watching it that show just like
man they jumped the shark oh yeah it was
fun it's like a dc superhero show but
now it's like turns out one guy's an
alien and now there's a bunch of aliens
and i'm just like i don't know what you
guys are talking about this is stupid
yeah it's just dumb
uncle ulysses says
ian you're the man keep being you wanted
to shout out a local podcast about the
supernatural and conspiratorial
coin doc pro
conspiracy indoctrination program give
it a shot oh is it is it cohen coin give
it a shot see if you like it cool cool
thanks man
all right let's grab some more
king
king kingfo panda says found bret on
tiktok this is my first ever super chat
i've been subbed for so long
it told me i couldn't chat because i
subbed while watching child content whoa
yeah had to unsubscribe unsubscribe to
chat spin the ufo
oh so if you have a child if you have
like chill like under 13 content up in
one window youtube won't let you
subscribe to over 18 shows weird
i think we're gonna have to make sure
chicken city is for adult only
because we we have um
we have uh short chicken gags that we're
making
and uh we were here with sheamus
and so we recorded one that's really
funny and it's basically
it's not meant for
it's like it's like maybe like six to
nine years old is probably the w where
it would be if it was like a kids show
but it's the kind of jokes where you
know an adult would like it too but then
we as we were like ad libbing we did one
really dark one
where it was you know roberto
he's got a daughter
you know chickens don't really have you
know they don't care and so it's about
line breeding which is when fathers and
daughters and sons and mothers breed
and uh i put it up on instagram but for
some reason it wouldn't it was shadow
band like nobody could see it and i was
like well it is particularly dark like
roberto was drunk and he was like where
are you and i'm like we don't show
anything it was just like lion breed and
like a card pops up and explains how
this happens they wouldn't allow it and
so i'm like maybe it shouldn't be you
know like the darkest of humor at all
and maybe we should just stick to the
gag humor the gag humor joke we have is
just roberto screaming and running
around flipping out i thought kids would
like it was like adult swim 2007 yeah
absolutely incredible yeah yeah i
thought it was good also the first few
like what what what like no words he's
drunk like
drunk mumbling from a chicken
and he's drinking mealworm ipa yes so
good yeah kent uh our animator kent
welling made that uh i put it up on
instagram they wouldn't let me and i was
like maybe it's because we say [ __ ] in
it so i'll censor that so now he says
you booker
you know so i don't know but maybe i'm
like maybe i maybe we should just stick
to the stuff that's like more family
friendly the one that we i it was funny
because i was talking to ken and i was
like hey here's the the sound that like
the voiceover stuff we recorded don't
make that one like i think we are just
you know being vulgar and i'm like make
the one where it's just like the kids
show where they're like counting how
many eggs they have and then roberto
screams and runs around going nuts and
i'm like it's just silly kid stuff and
he's like you got it and then you
message me and messages me
sends the clip and he says it has been
made
and i'm like this one looks a little
shorter than it should be and i played
it and i was just laughing there's got
to be a network
instagram wouldn't let it go i don't
know they they function maybe fox rumble
i think it's too hot for fox rumble
hey advertisement
that's the one that's it after 10pm
really good
all right let's uh
adrian contreras says i'm going i'm not
going to smash the like button tim but i
will tickle it ever so gently
i'm still pushing for glenn jacobs on
the show too can we make that happen
we'll take a look
c santos says my fiance is gen z and she
can't stand the content that that brett
makes she thinks it's over critical and
bullying i've been trying to get her to
understand the culture war that's
happening but no luck so far
i think i think that's the thing about
the challenge of the culture war is that
if you
if like if someone walked up to you and
slapped you in the face
and then you were like guys i'm really
angry this guy's been slapping me in the
face let me explain to you people are
going to be like why are you being so
mean to that guy like i don't even know
who that guy is like they'll assume that
your criticism of legitimate things is
mean yeah or wrong and it's like bro i'm
not the person who's throwing paint in
someone's face you know like they're the
ones throwing pain in us it's funny it's
funny to hear that though because i do
get criticism for being
too empathetic to people though from
people on the right who are like i did
an episode about emma watson and i you
know or there was something i was doing
with demi lovato who was like i still
really like music like i think she's
fantastic like that kind of thing people
are like how dare you say nice things
about her and it's like we're still
human beings you can still criticize
people and the ridiculous things that
they do and find humor in it and still i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say bullying
i've been watching your stuff and like i
mean honestly like it's uh
you definitely have your style but i
think it's from
from certain perspectives like you have
people saying that you're being too
empathetic and other people saying
you're bullying it's well if you're on
the internet you can't please everybody
so yeah you're kind of like okay with
the comments if this is like uh joe
rogan would tell people don't read the
comments but you actually have a show
called the comment section and i love
reading the comments just don't take it
personally any of it the good stuff or
the bad stuff it's hard not to take the
good stuff personally when like you're
so awesome i love when you did this
thing and you're like yeah me too uh but
don't take it personally because then
you start to take the negative stuff
personally yeah exactly all right well
here's terry taramoto junior says brett
cooper thanks for selling me on
homeschooling on your instagram for when
i have kids already hated public schools
before it was cool to hate uh cool to
hate them so it wasn't difficult but
your stuff on homeschooling is what made
what made me decide that was the
solution amazing that actually makes me
very happy that's awesome homeschooling
legit so good
wouldn't have changed the thing
dan yela sanchez says hey guys i want to
audition for the daily wires upcoming
productions as an actor how can we how
can one find out how to audition if i
have to relocate to nashville i will do
it have an awesome day guys well uh
brett you run casting for daily wire
right yeah yeah obviously that's my
that's my other job i actually have i
get a lot of people we have a lot of
people that dm me asking for jobs are
like how do you find you know career's
not gonna think i actually have no idea
how the casting process goes for the
films but i will say
if you're trying to work at daily wire
you can go to our career page it's not
too difficult to find and it is funny
when i have people being like how where
do i find it you can type in daily wire
careers if you really are
motivated to come work for us i promise
you you will find a way yeah ken
pittsburgh says we are already in the
metaverse when we die
the carney will take you off take take
off your vr glasses you'll ask how long
you're in there and he'll point to a
sign that says five dollars for five
minutes chicken city yeah wow yeah it's
like uh rick and morty when they go to
blitz and chits that you know have you
guys seen that one have you seen it
he's like let's go play roy and you sit
down and you put this headset on and
then you just like you go limp and then
you live an entire life as some guy
named roy
and they're like they're watching morty
play
and then after he comes out he's like
where am i i'm i'm morty and and rick is
like you went back to the carpet store
jeez let me play and then everyone's
watching and they're like whoa he's
taking this guy off the grid he doesn't
have a social security number
yeah it was funny he's taking him off
the grid
roy
all right seriously jk says the other
day i tweeted at elon musk to buy all of
twitter and then immediately shut it
down i have not heard back from him yet
but i'll keep you all posted i mean
if elon musk doesn't get in it's doomed
anyway
if he if elon musk gets the company
he'll fix it so
you know
3d pyromaniac says brett should go on
mug club and play newest gender pronouns
now what is this is that uh crowder yeah
it i'll be at blaze next week cool yeah
awesome
that's in austin right uh dallas dallas
dallas yeah i was there how did i get
that run
all right
and slave said tim it would be awesome
if you checked out music my new album is
called defund the politicians search
enslaved ones on here or any streaming
service hey man always interested in
people making culture and succeeding
with it so
zoidberg says
i constantly promote free the code but
that's no guarantee that the open source
code is the same code that's running on
the live system interesting
yeah
shinobi strong side ian i have i have
i have that time dilations almost every
night it was so bad i had to go on
disability living whole lives in one
night eventually i learned how to manage
it time is definitely illusion oh
interesting yeah i'd love to find out
how you managed it too that was very
cool i wonder if that's like a uh
something that a lot of people have
experienced
like let's actually get a name because
that's that that'd be a wild
disorder to have
like each night living a full life
geez that'd be pretty well check this
out dragon lady says deep space nine
episode hard time o'brien lives a
20-year prison sentence that's implanted
in his brain in a few hours causes a
bunch of psychological problems
afterward great episode
crazy very cool yeah what if what if all
were all this is right now our lives are
actually
a metaverse
we're all three years old
and the point is to give you a full life
of experience and wisdom so you come out
you're three and you're like whoa and
they're like
we wanted to make sure that before you
started you knew what you were doing so
i will eat less sugar as a teenager
see
they're gonna you're gonna come out
you're gonna be three and you're gonna
be like i'm
alive
i what am i and they're gonna be like
what did you learn like what what did
you learn
i'm not going to eat sugar when i'm a
teenager you pass keep going
that's great someone else is like i want
donuts yeah back in
bed
[Laughter]
yeah
all right uh
king
king dem
says our king to me says tim we already
have the metaverse for years it's called
vr chat the videos about journalists
living in the metaverse for days are not
original at all there's literally dozens
of videos of the same kind what facebook
did is not relevant no i understand so
when we we when we talk about metaverse
it's typically you know in reference to
the coming brain implants where they
stick the metal into your neck and then
you actually are in the metaverse
through a neural net
yeah see i think
i think i feel like most guys would say
yes instantly
yeah i was watching i want to fight a
dragon bro yeah i've been seeing videos
of people going into the metaverse
they'll be like i was in the metaverse
for 30 days and there's like a youtube
video about it and they said one guy was
saying that a lot of people noticed just
look at look into mirrors and stare at
themselves what you'll see groups of
people just staring at themselves in a
mirror in the metaverse like
did you ever see that thing where they
put vr headsets
on on people a man and a woman they
stood in front of each other but their
vr headsets were each other's
camera
so the man they would like both of you
look down slowly
and then they would like now feel your
body and they they would feel their body
the same way but the dude was seeing the
woman's body and the woman was seeing
the dude's body so it's like when you
touch your hands you feel like you're in
the other person's body oh that's so
weird yeah
creepy yikes yeah and then they have
like touch your leg and so you feel like
because you're seeing in the in the
lenses the other body that's mirror
neurons gone
yeah that's that's what allows when when
you see somebody crying or somebody fall
and scrape their knee or something like
that your mirror neurons empathize to
the point where you can feel it
that's crazy yeah
i think the illness yeah there's a guy
like that sometimes too
in
like in skateboarding whenever you watch
slam videos you can feel the slam i
don't i it's crazy like i'll watch them
hit the ground and i feel the jolt in my
body i'm like oh man
don't like that crazy right yeah you
know
they say that if you don't experience
that that like sociopaths don't
experience that phenomenon so it's like
how they test for it they'll show you
they'll show you a vid they'll show a
video of someone getting hurt in some
way and if you don't have a response
they think
you know something's there
yeah
yeah that's why i can't stand how you
just i'm like i turn on instagram and
too many videos are slams i'm like dude
if i see a slam coming i just i'm
getting out because i'm gonna you you
don't feel it but you feel it you know
what i mean you get that feeling
all right
let's grab some more super chats what do
we got
d stuff says have you guys heard of
vince dow and the american populist
union he's someone i've been a fan of
for a little while you should have him
on the show keep with the good work i do
not know who that is i'm gonna write
that down he's a good guy i know i'm
from prageru oh he's a really sweet kid
yeah cool not kid i guess he's no he's a
little younger than me yeah party hard
jay says twitter moderation has gotten
so bad that i got suspended today for
asking you if redneck riviera would be
open to the public tomorrow what it was
labeled hateful conduct and my appeal
was denied email you guys screenshots
wow because redneck probably wow
here's the plan
redneck riviera exists it is john rich's
venue we have no formal plan with the
venue other than john rich owns it and
he said let's go jam and i said okay so
if it's open it's open if it's not i
have no idea what's going on
at 1 30. that's the plan 1 30 p.m yep
yeah ian's gonna headline it's all we're
gonna put banners up for for him i'll be
screaming you know play some songs i
guess uh you're gonna be there ben i'll
play something yeah uh carter will be
there he's you know from tim cast so uh
i think everyone will be able to get in
as much as they want to play i'll
probably i'll probably only play a
couple songs i might even have to leave
early just because we got to get on the
road but actually no probably not you
going oh maybe i'll come oh wow don't
put yourself in there
you play music yes nice but i don't play
any instruments at the very least if you
do come i think i'm like john this place
is going to be so packed because people
are going to drive up people are going
to head out i mean it's not it's
downtown nashville yeah
already on a saturday
but but john rich is announcing on the
show he is going to be there so like
yo john rich of big and rich yeah i'm
like i don't know who i'm talking about
i'm like don't look at me i'm like
you're telling people you're doing a
show people are going to show up it's
going to be crazy and he's like yeah
yeah of course it's always packed and
i'm like all right man i think we're
gonna need like the car pulled around
back because we got it we got a hard
stop we got to get on the road
we've got missions to accomplish
all right ben says great video this
morning tim quote i wake up every day
and lay a brick great message bad
wording very bad yeah wow no bricklaying
i'm totally fine with it in fact if it
made people laugh all the better every
day i wake up i lay a break
what is that like like
a brick that's also good for you it
works for me my body is a machine and it
cranks out large rectangular bricks
and then i take and i go this is mine
and i slam it onto the building that i'm
making and magical there you go every
day [ __ ] house okay yeah every day
you add a brick
every day you add a brick i love this
what that means is you know
where we are now with this crazy
fifth wheel trailer in the daily wire
parking lot doing shows with you know
these guests it's not like one day i
woke up and i wrote down here's how you
do all this thing was like every day i
was just like i will place this brick
right here on this building and one day
you look you take a step back 20 feet
and you're like this thing's huge it
just happens one one step at a time
christina h says miss cooper i love your
show happy friday cast have fun tomorrow
we will we're going to be driving a lot
oh yeah
good times jdc gaming says there are
only 31 possible plots that have ever
been created for movies and i kind of
feel like that's true yeah
is there a villain's journey
you know
is there there is yeah well there's the
hero's journey which is the famous you
know story
map architecture i wonder if it's a
villain's journey i think the whole
megamind thing maybe i don't want to be
the bad guy no that's a hero's journey
there's one
turning into a hero yeah it's just he's
still a hero yeah the watchman um the
cartoon that's played throughout the
movie that guy on the pirate ship do you
remember this cartoon incredible and he
i'll tell the story i guess um he's
trying to get back home the pot his ship
is raided by pirates and everyone is
killed except for him and he's on a
lifeboat trying to get back to his wife
and family but he knows that these
pirates are going to kill them so he
spends just weeks paddling to get there
as his crew is rotting starts to rot and
then he starts to hallucinate and they
come alive and they're like you did this
to me and he's losing his mind he
finally gets back and he's this wild
animal looking to kill these pirates and
the town is crazy and in the shadows he
sees one of them and he kills them and
it turns out the pirate he killed was
actually his wife oh my god he became
the demon that he sought to destroy hmm
i like mr freeze better
you know mr frieza's story you're young
so i get to tell you
you know most comic book villains were
like i'm going to take over the world
but mr freeze in the batman animated
series his wife was terminally ill so he
was siphoning funds from the corporation
he worked at to work on research to save
her life while keeping her frozen so she
wouldn't die and when the boss finds out
he comes in and he's like this is what
you've been doing with my money shut it
down he's like no you'll kill nora and
then he gets hit with all these
chemicals becomes mr freeze and then he
becomes a villain his motivation is he's
trying to save his wife so mania it's
obsessive love it's a type of love that
can twist people i think it's just love
it's like a guy who's willing to do
whatever he has to do to save his wife
at at the expense of others the greeks
they've just derived eight types of love
one of them is mania and that's means
obsessive love there's like arrows which
is erotic love there's pragma which is
like pragmatic love like paleo brotherly
love
nah nah nah it's
mr freeze it was just
romantic love romantic love and and the
reason he's a good villain it's because
it's love and loyalty
but selfishness that he didn't care who
he hurt
he was creating the same problem the
people he hurt when he was trying to
save his wife are experiencing the same
pain that he's experiencing but doesn't
care so it's narcissism and romantic
love but it's an i was it's it's it was
brilliant i think they want an emmy for
it love it
all right
let's grab some a couple more super
chats as we go through we got we got
time for a couple more
john smiths haven't used reddit since
they banned the donald it was basically
them outright admitting they were
absolutely partisan it's no longer a
place to share content it's a place to
spread propaganda yeah i go on reddit
all the time
and when i see these people be like
social media isn't biased what they're
just trying to do is shut up you go on
reddit and it's like there there was two
subreddits hit the top of all from me
saying i don't i went to a diner and i
didn't want to wait because they sat
someone in front of me and it was like
the right can't meme posted it and i'm
like what is me
have telling a story about not waiting
at a diner which was me intentionally
telling a story about me being
disagreeable and kind of annoying
sometimes have to do with right-wing
politics at all but that's what you get
when you go on reddit
rarely do you see anything that is uh
against the establishment it's always
sometimes you'll see our slash
conservative make it up there
but right now it's like elon musk wants
to buy twitter every comment is oh this
is bad and wrong every story is elon is
a goblin
yeah yeah yeah elon's great we look we
love what he's doing
all right we got room for a couple more
babic says hi i sent an email to spin
the ufo please check it out also how can
i pitch my tech company idea to take
over big tech to the daily wire is there
an email
i don't know if brett has the answers to
those questions oh yeah you know me and
all my powerful knowledge yeah as the
casting director yeah
that's true
all right
txp says my 17 year old daughter just
told me she wished technology would go
away i told her about emp
well there you go perfect right on
all right zombie lord says the villain
story is the greek story of
uh
phys uh
physicist physicist this physics this
interesting where
or is it uh phys fizzius
where the main where the main is forced
to roll a boulder up a hill for it to
fall to the bottom in a cycle it's
sisyphus isn't it oh yeah sisyphus oh
yeah but they yeah but you know
what they wrote as physicists yes
sisyphus yeah yeah he was pushing up the
boulder but he couldn't interesting only
to follow the bottom of a cycle one can
only work for the power they can have
absolutely all right we'll grab this uh
this
we'll grab this one here brenton connor
says ghost in the shell freaks me out
about nora link ghost in the shell is
legit good show you you've seen it
mm-hmm yeah if you're interested in
metaverse stuff just check it out
it's uh in the future people have like
prosthetic bodies
so their brain or ghost is put into a
different body or they get like
prosthetic eyes and all this weird stuff
cool stuff ladies and gentlemen it's
friday night in nashville we're gonna go
party if you haven't already smash that
like button smash it for ian
crush it don't be afraid of technology
it's neutral just use it properly well
make sure
[Laughter]
head over to timcast.com become a member
support our work you guys are the
lifeblood of the company and we are only
able to do this because of all of you
who sign up and enjoy our members only
content monday through thursday at 8 pm
so we really do appreciate it you can
follow the show at tim cast irl we have
reels on instagram so you can catch
short clips throughout your day you can
follow me at tim cast i guess if you
want to see weird things on twitter and
me talking nonsense it's a lot of fun
brett you want to shout anything out
yeah you can go subscribe to the
comments section we do it every day five
days a week it's a good time i know i go
through the comment section so you don't
have to it's really benevolent to be
honest wow thank you very much what's
your social media i'm brad cooper on
everything all right
ben
yeah go to ben
josephstewart.com that's where you can
find all my work i'm doing a lot of
documentaries lately and uh pushing the
envelope of conscious media
ian crossland happy to see you guys this
was a fantastic week in nashville brett
thanks for having us to the daily wire i
appreciate it happy to have you you
putting it together for us for
everything is ahead of production or
whatever obviously but really this has
been a spectacular uh opportunity and
i'm so glad tim thanks for having me and
this is just great you guys so thanks
for being here with us and i will see
you guys next week yeah this week was
absolutely an adventure thank you guys
everyone for tuning in as we mashed it
up with the daily wire that was a
freaking blast i really hope that we can
do this again it's a great time i met
some great people learned some cool new
stuff and did some interesting
technological things so
hopefully we can just go further next
time i'm stoked anyway you guys can
follow me on twitter minds.com at
sarahpatchlets or at
sourpatchlids.me
ladies and gentlemen just the other day
chicken city
generated
1
495 dollars so head over to youtube.com
chickencity or chickencitylive.com
we are going to make gag short cartoons
that are family friendly i i know we
made a not family friendly one but
apparently i can't upload that anyway
and uh we are we are working on a plan
for a terrestrial television
commercial that i would love to get on
tucker carlson and so uh chicken city's
been a great success it's a relaxing
show where you watch chickens make
chicken sounds and uh you can check that
out while we while we're off hanging out
for the weekend at youtube.com chicken
city thanks for hanging out and we'll
see you all next time
you